[Musik]
morgens bequem arbeiten im home office
über mittag ein workout mit freunden und
abends zum konzert am anderen ende der
welt
alles kein problem
und nur ein klick entfernt
so jedenfalls versprechen ist die
visionäre des sogenannten meta works
facebook gründer mark zuckerberg etwa
ist
von einem virtuellen erfahrungsraum
unbegrenzte möglichkeiten der sich
genauso echt und authentisch anfühlt wie
unsere realität
der hype um die neue meter welt mit
eigenen währungen waren immobilien und
vergnügungs angeboten ist bereits heute
enorm schon jetzt werden mit rein
virtuellen produkten hunderte milliarden
dollar umgesetzt
doch auf welcher materiellen und
ökologischen basis nach welchen gesetzen
reguliert von wien
globalen konzernen anstatt
demokratischer regierungen
und jetzt mal ehrlich haben wir nicht
bereits mit unserer analogen welt mehr
als genug zu tun
philosophen von epikur bis nietzsche
wussten es gehört zum wesen des menschen
sich und seine welt ständig neu zu
erschaffen
ist das hier nur der nächste digitale
schritt oder leben wir grüne diktat
vermutete schon immer in einem meter
wörz nur ohne es zu wissen
schönes neues matters albtraum oder
utopie flucht oder aufbruch
das metermaß albtraum oder utopie flucht
oder aufbruch vielleicht auch nur ein
weiteres künstliches paradies das wollen
wir heute diskutieren am philosophischen
stammtisch mit anna verena nosthoff
philosophin co direktorin des data
politics lab an der humboldt universität
zu berlin sowie dominik er hat
philosophie leitender redakteur online
beim philosophie magazin sowie dir der
einzigartig und allzu realen barbara
bleisch wieso allzu real frage natürlich
auch mit dir war schreiben ich hoffe du
bist wirklich tatsächlich her ich fühle
mich so dass freunde
ja um da in die virtuelle welt
einzutauchen muss man ja eigentlich
idealerweise sich so eine brille
aufsetzen sie von haus hof haben mir
erzählt dass sie erst kürzlich zum
ersten mal so ein ding sich auf gesetzt
haben und es wurde unglaublich richtig
übel dabei genau also ich hatte
teilweise etwas migräne ich hatte
kopfschmerzen mein partner hat er die
sogenannte v ersten ist also die vr
krankheit von der ich ehrlich gesagt
vorher auch gar nicht wusste dass sie
eigentlich existiert ja das kann man
sich etwas vorstellen wie die
seekrankheit also das hat man wirklich
schwindelgefühle das hat teilweise auch
tatsächlich einige stunden an und also
es nicht die brille die erfahrung es war
nicht der brüller ich muss dazu sagen
ich habe einige vr applikationen
ausprobiert die ich eigentlich ganz
interessant fand also zum beispiel gibt
es ja unterschiedliche vr fitness
anwendungen wo man wirklich mit anderen
personen in einem raum ist also dann
teilt sich einen raum mit anderen
personen und das ist in vielerlei
hinsicht zu einer fusion eigentlich aus
fitness und game gaming also gern
easycash man hat es hier zu tun
teilweise mit virtuellen objekten die
auf einzufliegen und man muss die dann
so wegboxen und da glaube ich ehrlich
gesagt dass da ein ganz kreativ großes
marktpotenzial drin steckt auch erhard
ich glaube sie sind unter uns ja der
erprobte
virtual reality brillenträger hier ja
das glaube ich auch ich mache das ich
mach das mittlerweile also anfangen 2020
und ich würde auch also ich kenne die
motion sickness die sie geschrieben
haben
für mich die erste anwendung die so
eingelöst hat was man ja oft über
virtual reality hört wenn man ist drei
in der welt man ist immer tief drin man
hat das gefühl die umgebung ist wirklich
eine umgebung und die reagiert auch auf
ein das hatte ich anfangen wie gesagt
anfang 2020 als wir andere leute nicht
mehr treffen konnten als wir viel vor so
saßen vor skype oder so und dann hat er
ein guter freund von mir die idee kommen
wir machen das mal in der virtuellen
realität da gibt es eine anwendung nennt
sich big screen das ist man ist
praktisch in dem raum und vor allem gibt
es eine große wiederum virtuelle
leinwand man kann sich dort filme
ansehen so dass wir dann so filme
ansehen in der virtuellen realität ist
so mittel spannend was aber funktioniert
ist dass man wirklich das gefühl hat man
ist mit diesen anderen leuten die
natürlich als avatare dastehen und man
kann sich das vorstellen so wieso
comicfiguren und ist mit anderen comic
figuren in einem raum und unterhält sich
über die verschiedensten dinge und wer
waren sie gar ich ja auch noch
interessant welchen avatar wählt man
sich diese spannende frage ich hab
damals tatsächlich versucht mich zu sein
also ich hab damals noch möglichst den
arbeiter- so gebaut dass er aussieht wie
ich man kann da aber natürlich das sieht
man ja auch in der vorstellung von von
metall die er dieses metalls auch planen
ganz viele verschiedene möglichkeiten an
dem man kann ein roboter sein oder ein
fuchs oder möchte oder eben so aber ich
war damals ich habe versucht mich zu
sein das ist ein wunderbarer satz das
versuchen wir alle die ganze zeit sind
auch in der lage dazu was mich verstört
an diesem thema als jemand der das von
außen zunächst betrachtet ist da gibt es
die eine these das ist überhaupt nichts
neues dieses mit förster es gibt schon
seit zehn oder 20 jahren und die andere
these dass wird es sowieso niemals geben
besonders verstörend menschen gibt es
die behaupten beides gleichzeitig die
sagen einerseits gibt es das schon und
zweitens wird es nie geben wie erklärt
man das also ich würde sagen
technologisch gibt es natürlich einige
vorläufer es gibt eine ganze geschichte
der virtual reality
mann hatte jahrelang das problem dass
man vr nicht wirklich kostengünstig
dass diese brille noch viel zu schwer
waren dann muss dazu sagen die sind auch
immer noch relativ schwer man merkt das
schon wenn man die auf hat mittlerweile
ist man aber so weit dass man das doch
in der breite ganz gut produzieren kann
und auf der anderen seite gibt es
natürlich wir haben das auch im
einspieler gesehen die ökologischen
kosten ja die ökologischen fragen die
eine große rolle spielen bei denen ich
auch so ein bisschen skeptisch wäre weil
die frage ist auch immer inwiefern ist
das eigentlich technologisch umsetzbar
was etwa mark zuckerberg sich davor
stellt und auch aus ökologischen aber es
ist man sich aber erst mal die
technologische und ist es denn möglich
ein rasen zu schaffen der realität
analog ist es ist ja die rede davon dass
man noch zehn bis zwölf bahnbrechende
neue technologien benötigt um überhaupt
das mittags umzusetzen in der form in
der etwa so mark zuckerberg oder auch
andere visionäre wie matchball sich das
vorstellen und insofern glaube ich schon
dass wir das hier immer noch mit einer
durchaus spekulativen erzählung über
eine mögliche zukunft was immer das auch
noch mal betonen dass sie haben ja schon
den begriff der immersion verwendet also
dieses totale eintauchen damit das
überhaupt möglich ist erreicht es
natürlich nicht nur seine brille zu
haben und einen leistungsstarken rechner
sondern es ist die rede davon ganzkörper
anzüge zu tragen die kosten moment
ungefähr zehntausend franken dann
braucht man handschuhe damit wenn ich
den den hund streicheln
meta war's ich spüre dass ich den hund
streicheln und dann ergänzt passieren
habe ich mir sagen lassen sie sind ja
der spezialist ergänzt sozusagen die
fehlenden sensorischen eindrücken also
man hat man das gefühl wenn man umarmt
wird er im metallbörse tatsächlich
umarmt zu werden aufgrund dieses anzugs
der handschuhe uns unseren eigentlich
extrem simpel gestrickten hirn das dann
ergänzt was wir sehen ja was sie
ansprechen da gibt es einen begriff
dafür dass virtual embodiment das haben
wir vor allem praktischen implizit
angesprochen das heißt wenn ich einen
virtuellen körper annehme ein avatar
annehme dann habe ich das gefühl wenn es
gut gemacht ist dass ich tatsächlich
diesen körper bewohner und das spannende
ist ja sowieso hineinkriechen 20
hineinkriechen genau also eine
verkörperung praktisch das wort aber da
ist ja auch spannender weise kommt ja
aus dem religiösen kontext vision ein
gott wenn wir uns einen indischen gott
vorstellen und der kommt auf die erde
und der hat damals ein avatar bewohnt
also auch da ganz spannend dass man die
religiöse begrifflichkeit jetzt auf die
technik überträgt machen könnte ja auch
die werden ochsen kinder stehen so das
sind alle mit diesem land mit diesem
körper gehen praktisch wir auch mit sohn
gottes geist in eine andere welt hinein
aber die dass das einsetzen von von
sensorischen wie marx sagte burger sich
das vorstellt und wie wir das auch in
ein spieler gesehen haben das wird die
nächsten zehn jahre so nicht realität
werden das sagen alle personen die da
wirklich an davon haben und es gibt auch
stimmen die behaupten und ich werde
jetzt auch dem nicht abgeneigt das
besonders meter das auch als ein
ablenkungsmanöver fährt aktuell wir
erinnern uns die facebook paper kam raus
wo man gehört hat wie facebook intern
über sich denkt über sich spricht wenn
sie denken dass man zu hören die wissen
nämlich sehr genau dass instagram
problematisch ist besonders für junge
menschen besonders für junge frauen so
und ich glaube durchaus dass ja dass
magdeburg sicher etwas vorstellt was wir
so lange noch nicht haben wir also
interessant die tatsache dass wir hier
dieses thema besprechen könnte schon
sein dass wir herrn zuckerberg auf den
leim gegangen sind dass wir nicht über
die probleme von meta sprechen sondern
über die vision die es dann dürfen aber
bleiben wir doch mal bei der vision bei
division ist sehr interessant jedes neue
produkt würde ich sagen hat ein
kernversprechen ist es richtig
verstanden wenn man sagt das
kernversprechen dieses neuen universums
besteht in der distanzierung von unserer
konkreten leiblichkeit der leib ist
träge er ist vielleicht nicht so wie wir
wollen und da gibt es ein universum in
dem wir die leiblichen grenzen die uns
alle gegeben sind spielend überwinden
ich würde sagen es geht eigentlich um
das wasserwerk als ziemlichen auch für
fillinger physische präsenz nennt da
hatten sie jetzt auch gerade darauf
hingewiesen also es geht tatsächlich um
die vorstellung dass man diese
leiblichkeit auch simuliert also sie
haben es gerade auch schon angedeutet es
geht in diesen matters darum dass ich
diese körperlichkeit auch durchaus
empfinde man kann sich natürlich die
frage stellen ist das dann authentisch
ist das echt ja oder ist das vielleicht
nur künstlich erzeugt aber das ist
sozusagen die vision dahinter es geht
schon darum dass man versucht das zu
simulieren auf der anderen seite würde
ich aber auch sagen es gibt natürlich
auch klare grenzen der simuliert ja die
frage ist sozusagen was ist der
materielle rest der sich nicht
simulieren lässt ja wenn wir an den tod
etwa denken wenn wir an die geburt des
stillens oder aber kann ich das wissen
wenn ich eine arbeiter frau wäre wie
sich das dann anfühlt genau und und das
ist natürlich auch so dass wir bestimmte
materielle voraussetzungen also dass
wohnen etwa ja das sind alles dinge die
brauchen wir müssen natürlich irgendwo
auch ein dach über dem kopf haben da
rettet und sozusagen auch eine vr brille
nicht ja im zweifelsfall das heißt es
gibt bestimmte materielle
voraussetzungen die erfüllt sein müssen
eine sache aber ich will nämlich auch
sagen was ja also das versprechen ist ja
dass wir praktisch in das match gehen
wie bigott und schuf so wir kommen da
alle rein und dann finden wir uns neu
und dann haben wir die möglichkeit eine
gerechte gesellschaft von grund auf
aufzubauen dem würde fundamental
widersprechen weil natürlich kommen wir
mit sozialen voraussetzungen da rein
natürlich kommen wir mit einer
bestimmten sozialisierung der 1 das
heißt wer jetzt hier viel geld hat hat
natürlich auch möglichkeiten sich daher
güter zu kaufen den andere vorenthalten
werden also diese idee von wir machen
alles neue wir werden jetzt gerechter
aber ich finde das interessant weil wir
dauernd am dekonstruieren der idee sind
und ich würde gerne die idee noch mal
stark machen obwohl ich jetzt gar nicht
so fraktion vr brille aber ich meine ich
mein das erstmal sich auszudenken dass
wir uns eben selbst erfinden können dass
wir uns selbst erschaffen selbst zur
welt bringen und eigentlich die grenzen
dessen leer sein kann was wir sein
können unsere fantasie ist und eben
nicht mehr die klasse wo ich komme meine
hautfarbe mein geschlecht sondern dass
ich das alles austauschen kann hat ja
erst mal was und dann würde ich noch
fragen weil du gesagt hast der kern ist
doch eigentlich dass wir unseren körper
verlassen können oder verändern können
bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher ich
finde zum beispiel etwas nicht daran
faszinieren würde ist dass ich viel
näher an den iran kann also ganz platt
gesagt ich muss mich halt nicht
anstellen wenn nicht die mona lisa sehen
will sondern ich kann da direkt mich vor
die mona lisa stellen da gibt es keinen
der da auch noch ist und vielleicht
schweiz transferiert oder ich irgendwas
alle diese dinge ich kann ganz nah ran
dann kommt die sehr interessante frage
ist es eigentlich interessanter die
sachen real zu erleben und wenn ja warum
ich würde vielleicht bevor wir zu der
frage kommt nochmal eine sache sagen zu
diesen diesem versprechen auf multiple
persönlichkeiten multiple identitäten
weil das ist auch ein sehr altes
versprechen dass auch den frühen tagen
des internets schon innewohnte jahr
diesen ganzen erzählungen des cyberspace
die waren sehr beseelt von diesem
versprechen dass man sich nicht auf eine
identität festlegen muss ja cherry türke
zb schreibt aber wie es möglich war in
unterschiedlichen zeiträumen
unterschiedliche identitäten
herauszubilden und das hatte damals auch
ein sehr würde ich sagen jemand die
partie was potenzial insbesondere eben
auch für ihre identitäten für die lgbt
schuhplus.com louis der identität genau
auch vor sehr sehr wichtig ist auch
natürlich um sich sozusagen jenseits
repressiver sozialer normen auch nicht
auf und die binäre geschlechtlichkeit
festlegen zu müssen ich würde aber sagen
dass dem natürlich über die hyper
kommerzialisierung des internets nun
sozusagen eine gegenteilige logik
entgegen steht nämlich die logik der
profilierung ja also mit mit den mit dem
aufstieg der plattform konzerne ist
natürlich auch insbesondere die
datenextraktion sehr wichtig geworden
und damit auch diese vorstellung dass
man profile sehr sehr passgenau
ausrichten kann ich würde sagen das ist
eigentlich eine sehr ambivalente tendenz
darf ich noch mal dieser gedanke dass
das ein emanzipatorisches potenzial hat
dass man sich neu ausprobieren kann
jetzt kann man sagen die versionen sowie
das genannt wird es ja überhaupt nichts
neues wenn ich in die geisterbahn gehe
auf der kirmes das ist auch eine
inversion und ich erfahre neues wenn ich
ins fußballstadion in die fankurve gehen
dann bin ich nicht der hallenberger da
bin ich der eile und leute kennen nicht
nur so eine harley davidson fahren meint
will ich auch wieder ein anderer so was
ich nicht so ganz verstehe wir kennen
immersion effekte aus unserem alltag
völlig ohne sogenannte virtuelle
realität brauchen wir da jetzt noch eine
andere dazu er ist natürlich noch mal
ein weiterer schritt wenn man sich
vielleicht die verschiedenen medien
anguckt die historisch historisch so gab
dann ist natürlich auch kann natürlich
auch ein text wahnsinnig intensiv seien
noch immer sie war wäre dann de facto
das radio da ist eine stimme die die zu
mir spricht und noch intensiver
vielleicht das fernsehen oder das kino
wo ich dann auch noch die bild die
bildinformation mit dazu bekomme oder 4
d kinos unter druck gesetzt und so und
ich glaube wir haben aber trotzdem noch
mal eine andere stelle bei der
virtuellen realität und zwar insofern
als dass hier wirklich diese verkörpern
haben und um das auch noch mal stark zu
machen um nicht zu sagen das ist alles
schlecht es gibt auch therapeutische
anwendungen die wahnsinnig sinnvoll sind
in virtueller realität zum beispiel um
einen um ein beispiel zu nennen es gibt
die anwendung freut mich von sigmund
freud
praktisch also angelehnt an den erfinder
der psychoanalyse und die idee ist man
tritt ein in einen virtuellen raum als
man selber man wird er vorgestellt und
hat dann genau das an und erzählt
sigmund freud seine probleme wie das
damals war in der kindheit und was die
eltern alles falsch gemacht haben und so
dann gibt es eine pause und man setzt
wieder ein ein headset auf und dann ist
man sieht man freud und sieht sich
selbst im raum gegenüber stehend wie man
sich selbst ein problem an cruise das
ist total gruselig aber das natürlich
auch eine sehr hoch gedrehte ein sehr
hoch gerätes beispiel aber die idee dass
man sich selbst im raum sieht mit all
den den komischen sachen die man macht
wenn man von problemen erzählt das hat
und aktiv wechseln ich nicht das hat
aber nachher braucht man eine reale
therapie in denen ich hinten und
schreiben dabei hilft so was ganz
einfach selbstverständlich aber
natürlich wenn wir sagen dass platzangst
zum beispiel ja das kann man
wahrscheinlich dass solche effekte oder
angst vor spinnen gewisse soziale
situationen einzuüben da kann man ja
gleich sehen dass das ein unglaubliches
therapeutisches potenzial in sicht aber
dass ich auch reden jetzt über die
richtigen sachen hier an diesen stand
ich weil ich sofort bänke klar klar
tolle anwendungsmöglichkeiten und sie
hatten schon die fitness geschichten
erzählt ich komme ja auch lustige spiele
vorstellen alles gut oder viele farben
auch das doch toll dann kann ich meine
oma irgendwie die weit weg wohnt dann
treffen am strand
wir machen noch zusammen lagerfeuer und
singen lieder und sie ist glücklich ich
bin glücklich alles super aber das was
da den vorschwebt und was sozusagen
diejenigen die dafür plädieren also zum
beispiel auch
ein philosoph der moment sehr
diskutierten sehr einflussreicher
philosoph muss man sagen der sich
durchaus der ansicht bakom ganz andere
dinge auf uns zu und das sind doch
eigentlich die die effekte die mich
interessieren also wirklich diese
vorstellung die tauchen regelmäßig ein
vielleicht sogar öfters wie die ins
reale leben eintauchen ins virtuelle
bieten und wir verschieben so mehr und
mehr unsere existenz individualität ist
das nicht eigentlich das thema ich
glaube es wird auf jeden fall dahin
gehen dass wir stärker an virtuellen
räumen uns bewegen ja das sieht man auch
anhand der technikentwicklung
mittlerweile sind wir ja so weit dass
wir also ein zuckerberg sagt das immer
so dass es darum geht dass wir uns
eigentlich durch mehr aktiv mit der
technologie auseinandersetzen müssen ja
er sagt die screens die devices sollen
weniger eine rolle spielen die sonne
eigentlich in den hintergrund unseres
daseins sozusagen zurück schreiten und
eigentlich nur ermöglichen dass wir teil
dieser virtuellen welten sein können und
da würde ich eben sagen man kann das als
als ferrum weltlichen eigentlich von
technologien beschreiben oder auch als n
parlament ali sierung so heißt es in der
medienwissenschaft aber die geht
natürlich auch einher mit einer
potenziellen ausweitung von
kontrollstrukturen da muss man natürlich
auch über diejenigen konzerne reden die
da eine große rolle spielen man muss
über datenextraktion sprechen man muss
über potenzielle zukünftige auch von
etwa politischer profilierung sprechen
also natürlich sind da auch große
gefahren mit verbunden insbesondere eben
mit dieser ausweitung eigentlich von
technologischen und digitalen
infrastrukturen und auch diesen sozialen
dem verschwinden des außen auch ja also
das ist hier sehr interessant dass man
sagt es gibt jede menge eine politische
probleme daran aber es gibt doch
zunächst einmal ein ökonomisches problem
und das ökonomische problem ist dass die
digitalisierung konzerne diese
expansions- erzählung diese 20 jahre
hatten nicht weiter fortführen können
dass die margen geringer werden dass die
gewinnerwartung erinnert an und jetzt
kommt jemand auf die idee und sagt okay
dann brauchen wir halt eine ganz neue
welt wir erobern die welt noch einmal
und zwar eine die wir selbst erfunden
haben also die welt ist nicht genug wir
sehen alle dass es hier irgendwie
knappheit gibt jetzt schaffen wir einen
ganz neuen raum in dem er finden wir das
geld die produkte die häuser alle
nochmal und die verkaufen wir dann
gleich auch noch mal ist das nicht
eigentlich das treiben der begehren
daran das ist auf jeden fall ein
begehren würde ich sagen und spannend
ist aber auch wenn man sich anguckt wie
funktioniert in diese neue welt weil oft
wird ja über das metas gesprochen dass
bis 2024 8 milliarden möglichkeit an
kapital haben soll so viel geld soll da
umgesetzt werden welche welche logik
folgt aber diese welt das ist ja nicht
eine welt wo wir hier die bedürfnisse
haben also wenn ich diesen tee trinken
würde dann wäre mein bedürfnis anti
erstmal für die nächste zeit gestellt so
weil wir unser leben erhalten müssen die
frage aber im meter was gibt's da dinge
die wirklich unser leben erhalten müssen
auf absehbare zeit nicht wir werden
immer noch sogenannte bio sims sein wir
werden uns immer noch hier eine
virtuelle realität brille aufsetzen und
dann ins bett gehen das heißt dann
könnte eine unterscheidung machen die
der philosoph kern und böhme eingeführt
hat und zwar zwischen bedürfnissen und
begehren essen begehren es sind etwas
die ziel nur auf den status ab die dinge
die meine begehrte stehen die brauche
ich eigentlich gar nicht eine teure uhr
noch schnelleres auto solche sagen das
metallgitter was wird es nur begeben
nichts von alledem brauchen wir
tatsächlich können vielleicht ganz kurz
ein beispiel machen also damit ist gut
verstehen also ich verstehe sie jetzt so
wenn ich ins kino gehe dann habe ich
vielleicht hunger und ich kaufe mir ein
eis oder ein sandwich was ist ein
bedürfnis ich esse dass ich ihn habe im
virtuellen kino kaufe ich mir auch ein
eis und zwar das teuerste das coolste
eis damit ich im kino gut aussehen und
es geht nicht darum dass ich ein
bedürfnis stille sondern ein begehren
toll auszusehen und da reicht auch das
nicht sondern ich brauche noch die uhr
und den tollen hut und die gucci
handtaschen keine ahnung genau oder
genau das ist ein beispiel oder stämme
und das noch ein bisschen grundlegender
vor ich kaufe meine mama zwar bestimmte
kleidung und das sieht alles super aus
und dann entscheidet meter oder je
nachdem welche welches unternehmen diese
plattform eben fühlt es gibt ein update
und all diese dinge die ich da gekauft
habe wir sind auf einmal nichts mehr
wert beziehungsweise ich brauche
wiederum neue sachen also auch hier
unternehmen entscheiden darüber was
unsere begehr nüsse sind ich würde sagen
wenn das zutrifft was sie sagen und
diese unterscheidung zwischen bedürfnis
und begehren hält unterscheidet sich
auch die form des konsums wir würden
nämlich alle nur noch was vor stein
blendend demonstrativen konsum haben
nicht mehr konsum der uns erhält sondern
der uns in anerkennungs verhältnisse und
distinguiert also alles was wir in
diesen meter was konsumieren ist
letztlich potts konsum weil wir brauchen
ist nicht wirklich genau es geht ja im
wesentlichen auch nur um beispielsweise
eine fts ja ich kann mir da eine falsche
diskussion fand schon bald token also
das ist im prinzip ein digitales
eigentumsrecht auf einen virtuellen
gegenstand auf basis von jobs an
technologien also im prinzip habe ich
dann sozusagen den nachweis dass mir
etwas gehört was aber rein virtuell ist
ja und auch hier kann man glaube ich
sagen das schließt glaube ich etwas an
das an was ich gerade gesagt hatten es
geht auch sehr stark um statussymbole in
der virtuellen welt also es geht zum
einen natürlich um spekulationen das
ganze ist ein riesengroßer
spekulationsmarkt und auf der anderen
seite aber auch glaube ich einfach nfc
objekte die wirklich viel mit showing
off zu tun haben und da würde ich eben
auch sagen es ist
also glaube ich grundlegend hinterfragen
ob das meta was eigentlich eine
utopische vorstellung ist weil sich das
soziale ungleichheiten reproduzieren
werden wir werden wahrscheinlich zu tun
haben mit räumen die wo ausschluss und
einschluss auch eine rolle spielen also
die kostenpflichtig sind die places to
be werden wahrscheinlich sehr teuer sein
als natürlich die frage wer kann da
eigentlich eintreten insofern würde ich
glaube ich generell auch mal
hinterfragen wie utopisch das eigentlich
ist ja wieder gerne noch ein beispiel
ein bringen uns auch noch mal deutlich
zu machen gerade kürzlich war in der nzz
am sonntag an die verlags beilage
zukunft bauen das shape staples auf das
youtube und die mavericks also meter das
wasser aus thema hier drin und das
beispiel die rede in der
immobilienbranche im die central and
also einem bereits existierenden
virtuellen land sozusagen war wurde
kürzlich ein landstück verkauft ein
grundstück für 450.000 franken das liegt
neben der villa des rapper snoop dogg
und da gibt es natürlich auch eben in
place place to be da gibt es die teure
einkaufsmeile usw 150000 franken der
fall schon aber wer kauft denn so was
das ist das eine und das andere ist was
sie zuletzt gesagt haben das macht mich
eigentlich tieftraurig fällt uns denn
eigentlich nichts besseres ein als noch
einmal genau das gleiche zu bauen sind
wir überhaupt nicht in der lage unseres
anderes auszudenken ja ich glaube da ist
ja auch so ein bisschen die frage sehen
wir virtuelle realitäten als real an
oder nicht und da sie haben es ja vorhin
schon kurz hochgehalten david charles
würde eher sagen nie virtuelle
realitäten sind auch real das ist
genauso also wenn ich in der virtuellen
realität eine freundschaft schließen zum
beispiel dann kann die ähnliche
funktionen haben wie eine freundschaft
hier in der physischen realität und
schauen was wird denn verschiedene
argumente an warum er sagt die virtuelle
realität hat auch realen status zum
einen ein festes kriterium sie existiert
sie kommt vor in diesem universum ganz
offensichtlich irgendwo stehen rechner
da gibt's schaltkreise da fließt strom
wir sehen etwas auf uns auf ihr appell
das zweite hat das grausame funktion
haben virtuelle gegenstände kaufen alle
funktionen ganz offensichtlich zum einen
auf andere gegenstände in der virtuellen
realität wenn ein virtuelles auto durch
die straßen fährt dann kann an dieser
stelle kein anderes virtuelles auto
fahren der coach sieht anders aus ich
mit meiner brille sehe dieses auto und
drittens und drittes kriterium ist es
unabhängig von unserem kopf ist
unabhängig von unseren geist wenn ich
mir jetzt denke dass mit albers vom
mieter sollen nicht existieren das
metermaß wird eventuell weiter
existieren und deshalb denkt er das ist
ja ich finde es furchtbar interessant
ich habe nur das gefühl dass das
philosophisch aufgeblasene trivialitäten
sind lehrer zum beispiel aus der
literatur wissenschaft schon lange kennt
natürlich haben romane als fiktionale
welten einfluss auf die reale welt die
leute lesen den wärter und bringen sich
danach um weil sie denken ich bin die
wörter also diese interaktion zwischen
fiktionalen welten und der welt die wir
die realität die gibt es seit es
menschen gibt ganz einfach weil menschen
fiktionale wesen sind es wäre auch gar
nicht leicht zu sagen was diese realität
im vergleich zu einer nicht fiktionalen
realität hier wäre das heißt die idee
dass ich dafür du so fisch neue probleme
stellen die kaufe ich nicht ich glaube
das ist einfach das ist die
ideengeschichtliche vergessen da kommt
etwas neues und mir denke wir haben ein
neues problem das problem gibt es seit
es menschen gibt vor allem ist ja auch
das wetter war selber zurückzuführen
eigentlich auch die science fiction
literatur also der begriff mit albers
und auch zum ersten mal auf 992 es
diesen snow crash
sie sich dann einen science fiction
roman der eben in einer ähnlichen form
wie zuckerberg jetzt das versucht auch
nachzubauen eine alternative virtuelle
realität schafft die sozusagen eine
antwort sein soll auf eine sehr
apokalyptische realität
weitere
entsprechend gibt es in anderen science
fiction romanen wie etwa in
ray player mann der auch verfilmt wurde
ja da gibt es eigentlich ein ganz
ähnliches szenario also auch vr ist
sozusagen ein eskapistische welt eine
mögliche alternative realität weil
eigentlich in der tatsächlich realität
ist kaum mehr menschlich ist zu leben ja
also das ist wirklich hochgradig
apokalyptisch und das interessante ist
dass mark zuckerberg seinen
mitarbeitenden auch diesen roman gegeben
hat als inspiration für das wetter ist
also insofern spielt science fiction
selber immer auch eine große rolle wenn
es um die herstellung von tatsächlichen
technologien geht ja also insbesondere
celik in berlin ich muss aber
fundamental ein haken weil ich bin
komplett andere
wenn wir nämlich sagen virtuelle welten
sind fiktional dann kaufen uns massive
probleme ein für die zukunft die wir
eventuell schaffen ein beispiel dann
wenn ich den roman lesen im roman sei es
mit schräger morning oder ohne ein
sexueller übergriff gestellt wird dann
bin ich nicht mit meinem körper tage
haben vorhin davon gesprochen dass wir
das gefühl hatten wir stehen da drinnen
der körper gehört mir wenn über
therapeutische anwendungen gesprochen
wie gehen wir denn mit sexuellen
übergriffen um zb zb in virtuellen
realitäten und
reisen reisen adventure also der die das
metall meters prototyp praktisch von
meta da gab es kurz nachdem launische
letztes jahr direkt den ersten sexuellen
übergriff so was haben die executives
also muss ich gleich ganz kurz erklären
sexuellen übergriff zwischen aber
inzwischen aber tagen das natürlich die
zu erklären also leute sitzen zuhause
der eine in toronto der andere in
bregenz an die virtuelle welt ihre
bilder auf treffen sich auf der straße
und der eine hat seine hand da wo er sie
nicht haben soll so
das wurde natürlich herangetragen an
meter und die haben gesagt ja die person
hätte einfach die safe sohn aktivieren
müssen was man sich vorstellen kann wie
so ein schutzschild was um einen hoch
geht dann sieht man ihn nicht mehr dann
kann man nicht mehr berührt werden dann
spricht man nicht mehr mit der person
dann kann man nicht mehr angesprochen
werden das heißt also da auch ist
irgendwo irgendwie die
eigenverantwortung dann sehr freuen kann
und weil auch neue existenz optionen
wären jetzt nicht einfach die safety
anstellen wird geht ein dort geht das
aber ich würde eben sagen wir müssen
also egal wie das mit was aussehen wird
oder so wir dürfen es nicht als
fiktionen begreifen weil sonst haben wir
auch im hinblick auf das strafmaß ist es
gut dass ich die fragen sich was ist
dann echt würden sie sagen das ist eine
echte sexuelle belästigung
nehmen wir also nehmen wir an dass meter
was wird wirklich so gut wie es ist wir
haben das gefühl wir sind da wirklich
drin dann würde ich sagen ja wenn eine
person mit der intention mir gegenüber
tritt in ihr etwas anzutun was ich nicht
möchte und ich fühle diesen körper so
wir leben da ja auch nach der idee wir
leben da ja nicht zwei stunden drin und
dann nächste woche ist spiel langweilig
geworden wir sind nun anderen sondern
die identifikation mit diesem virtuellen
körper wird wahrscheinlich größer werden
von daher würde ich sagen ja wir müssen
das natürlich ist die bildungs
hochgeladen unbedingt unterstreichen ja
genau also virtuelle belästigung ist
reale belästigung wir haben das auch auf
social media gerade man muss ja auch in
der lage sein justiziabel zu machen also
auch die personen die dafür
verantwortlich sind zur rechenschaft zu
ziehen und das kann ich natürlich nicht
wenn ich einfach sagen dass es einfach
nur ein virtuelles erlebnis eine
erfahrung dass das würde ich glaube ich
problematisch finden wir werden auch
manipulationen geben aber ich finde den
vergleichen social media noch schwierig
weil ich jetzt mehr vorstellen denn
jemand auf twitter beschimpft wird dann
ist ja der punkt dass man die person
trotzdem in der realen welt auf die
person empfindet die beschimpft wird als
auch wenn das auf social media
stattfindet was ich interessant finde
ist dass sich insgesamt denke es gibt
auch schon viele fälle bei denen man
merkt leute verlieben sich auf einer
dating plattform und die leute schreiben
sich ganz lange die treffen sich nie die
schreiben sich und plötzlich entscheidet
der eine r meldet sich da nicht mehr und
da ist natürlich die andere person unter
umständen wirklich tief gekränkt sie
trauert um diesen kontakt und es kann
man sich fragen war der kontakt real
natürlich war der kontakt real die haben
sich ja geschrieben und insofern
verstehe ich sofort auch was es
zumindest so was wie enttäuschung
verletzung geben kann wird ja auch die
frage gestellt was ist wenn ich ein
freund habe aus aber trauer ich verliebe
mich mit der person und irgendwann
entscheide ich konnte einfach nicht mehr
auf was ist natürlich eine große nein
ein moralisches brasilia einer
freundschaft medien eine kurze sache
dazu sagen dafür ist ghosting ist aber
natürlich auch nichts was man gewinnt
nur auf die virtuelle realität
reduzieren kann sondern das ist eine
soziale praxis die wir auch sozusagen
aus dem zeitalter schon kennen wo es
keine digitalen kommunikationsmittel gab
es gibt studien dazu die belegen dass
die digitale kommunikationsmittel das
durchaus auch etwas erleichtern weil die
andere person vielleicht nicht mehr so
leicht nachzuverfolgen ist und so weiter
aber dennoch für dich eben sagen das ist
eine soziale praxis und das ist gibt
natürlich virtuelle entsprechung dieser
sozialen praxis und insofern würde ich
sagen aber ich meine großen kennen wir
aus unserem nachbarschafts
bekanntschaften ja papa gibt
zigarettenholen papa kommt nicht wieder
so was gibt es in der realen welt auch
also das closing ist keine virtuelle
währung habe ich nochmal die elefanten
im raum für innovationen machen digitale
technische innovation war die letzten 40
jahre innovation die die pornoindustrie
als erstes adaptiert hat die dazu erst
kommerzielle waren und die zuerst
funktioniert haben mir scheint es nun
ganz evident dass in der pornografie
diese form von räumen einen
unglaublichen boom auslösen werden und
eine riesen perspektive haben ja das ist
auf jeden fall der konsole also es gibt
einschlägige vorne plattform wo man
jetzt schon mit virtual reality eben
diese erfahrung machen kann die sie
ansprechen
das also dass es dem unbenommen ich
glaube ein problem wird es dann wenn wir
da auch als mieter wird denken wie zum
beispiel ein altes metapher second life
vielleicht erinnern sich die älteren
semester auch noch damals 2003 gegründet
2008 war der große hype mit über acht
millionen leuten ähnlich aber ohne
brille man hat ein avatar stellt nicht
einfach am computer konnte diesen aber
durch eine virtuelle welt steuern und da
gab es auch immer wieder bereiche die
von terror groups terrorisiert wurden
und eben überall gab sexuelle handlungen
und sowas und da merkt man auch schon
was probleme sind in die wir laufen wenn
wir irgendwie ins mitte west denken da
gab es nämlich eine zeitung den
alphaville herald eine interne eine
interne zeitschrift von nutzerinnen und
nutzern die gesagt hat mensch eigentlich
müssen wir linden lab second life
verantworten schreiben und sagen wir
brauchen ordnung in diesen zonen das
kann nicht sein dass da diese ganze
trolle rumlaufen und da diese ganzen
handlungen folgen reine anarchie so
reine anarchie was hat linden lab
gemacht die haben diese zeitung
abgeschaltet die haben die zensiert so
also eben nicht von oben ordnung
gebracht mittlerweile ist alles wieder
beruhigt aber auch einfach weil die
leute den weg gegangen sind und einige
nutzer können nutzer von second life
haben dann eine eigene version von
second life gemacht opens in die
demokratische organisiert ist das heißt
dass wird demokratischer einfach die
entscheidungsprozesse laufen da unter
allen aber wie ist es denn jetzt ganz
real wenn so etwas passiert so einer
vergewaltigung oder nehmen wir mal an
jetzt pornoindustrie es gibt hat sich
räume da kann man pädophile pädosexuelle
handlungen vollziehen gibt es denn da
regulierung gibt es da kann man doch
klagen irgendwo also bei meta was ist es
ja so dass viele die die aufgabe haben
zu regulieren momentan noch nicht so
richtig wissen welche fragen sie
eigentlich stellen soll einfach weil es
mit einer hoch gerade spekulativen
technologie zu tun haben die noch nicht
richtig aus geformt ist bei der man auch
nicht genau weiß wie sich die
machtkonstellationen daraus
buchstabieren werden ja ich gehe
persönlich davon aus dass wir es so
wiebels von social media kennen so wie
es generell aus der dinge ökonomie
können dass es da mit einer fortführung
von macht akkumulation zu tun haben bei
der sicherlich die großen player auch
eine rolle spielen werden ich würde aber
sagen dass man jetzt schon bereich
erkennen kann wo sehr evident ist dass
man dort regulieren muss also natürlich
der ganze bereich der content moderation
man sieht genau inhalts moderation man
sieht dass anhand dieser dieser
strategie von facebook die das auch
angegangen wurde ja dieses problem
einfach wieder zu sagen ich würde keine
content moderatorinnen aus sondern ich
eher sinn ein technologisches feature
das die userinnen dann aktivieren müssen
also diese safe so ein feature ja da
wird sozusagen wieder die verantwortung
eigentlich auf die userinnen abgewälzt
das ist nur sehr typische strategie im
silicon valley aber ist das paradox wenn
ich eigentlich klar in dem maße in dem
dieses versprechen eingelöst wird wird
das einlösen dieses versprechens alle
probleme erzeugen die wir in dieser welt
auch das ist das was mich traurig macht
dass ich denke wo ist denn eigentlich
unser utopisches vermögen habe politisch
heißt das doch auch wir haben fragen
oder judikative der legislative der
exekutive brauchen da eine polizei wir
brauchen eine regierung wir brauchen bei
richter wir müssen alles verdoppeln oder
nicht ich würde sagen ich hatte das eben
schon angedeutet das problem ist dass
viele die jetzt regulieren müssten
einfach noch nicht genau wissen was das
eigentlich wird ja was daraus entsteht
auf der anderen seite haben wir
natürlich jetzt aber den usa sind in
digital services act im digital markets
act und da würde ich sagen das ist
durchaus eine errungenschaft man sieht
auch dass wir auf eu ebene durchaus in
der lage sind auch regulierend
einzugreifen
insbesondere natürlich was monopol
tendenzen gibt an betrifft ja die
spielen auch bei meta war schon rolle
das kann man alles schon sehen ja wie
facebook sich verhält wie facebook sich
zum beispiel verhält gegenüber
wettbewerbern auf der eigenen plattform
oder auch gegenüber creators die dort
inhalte zur verfügung stellen kann die
müssen 50 prozent gebühren zahlen an
facebook also ruhig gestaltung eines
profitieren markt ja auf facebook nicht
mehr selbst marktteilnehmer ist sondern
diesen markt zur verfügung gestellt aber
zu eigens definierten bedingungen und
das vorgehen kennt man von apple
beispielsweise von amazon und ich glaube
da kann man schon relativ eindeutig
sehen in welche richtung das geht die
gesetzgeber die regulatoren sind aber
sehr viel alerta die sind sehr viel
wacher als noch vor einigen jahren als
meine persönlichkeit ich habe
gesetzgeber mit ja um was halten sie von
der ausgabe aussage dass man sagt naja
man kann sich entscheiden ob man da
reingeht oder nicht wenn man da reingeht
muss man auch lernen mit diesen
schutzschild aktivieren ich meine man
muss ja nicht geben man muss vielleicht
auch nicht in diese welt reingehen also
machen jetzt nicht ein problem größer
als es ist weil viele leute werden sich
vielleicht ja einfach schlicht nicht
interessieren ja das ist auch so ein
bisschen das argument von der wirtschaft
er sagt auf einer seite diese
grundprämisse seiner seines gesamten
buches ist eigentlich einmal zooming
schwenkbar ist afrikas also er geht
davon aus dass dieser eintritt in eine
freie wahl ist ja das ist für mich
einige moralphilosoph erkennung wenn man
davon ausgeht dass man eine relation hat
zwischen individuum und technologie aber
die gesellschaft eigentlich gar nicht
existiert und auch gesellschaftlicher
druck nicht existiert das sozialer druck
nicht existiert und wir sehen das ja von
sozialen medien das ist durchaus
kostspielig sein kann wenn ich nicht
teil davon bin einige berufszweige sind
existenziell darauf angewiesen und wer
zum beispiel genau als akademiker innen
als forscher in als journalistin ist es
schon kostspielig wenn ich nicht total
davon bin wenn ich meine inhalte nicht
einem breiteren publikum darüber zur
verfügung stellen kann und dahingehend
würde ich eben sagen müssen wir immer
sehen dass ab dem zeitpunkt wo diese
technologien zu einer sozialen normen
werden also wo sozialität sich in diesen
räumen abspielt gibt es glaube ich diese
vorstellung nicht mehr vom individuum
das sich für dagegen an der technologie
entscheiden kann sondern da gibt es eine
viel größere gesellschaftliche
einbettung und die müssen wir immer
mitdenken an normativen druck des
faktischen genauso zu sorgen wenn jetzt
auch noch über meter ehemals facebook
sprechen dann gibt es auch dieses eine
paper von 2018 jason wu wien wo er das
erste mal als als ein oculus executive
das heißt einer der diese brillen gebaut
hat das ist die die firma die meter dann
gekauft hat er schreibt an vorstände im
facebook facebook vorstand eben wir
müssen müssen schnell sein sodass
metallbörse das muss unser dass sein
spannender weise eben die idee des meter
werden wir reden jetzt nur über mieter
es gibt ja aber jetzt schon andere
anwendungen die ähnlich funktionieren
und meta weshalb eigentlich müssen wir
die alle crashen wir müssen das einzige
sein das heißt die sachen die man bei
uns kauft die können nicht übertragen
werden in andere anwendungen also dieser
monopol charakter den sie ansprechen der
ist eben nicht nur in den facebook
papers jetzt auf die aktuelle lage zu
beziehen sondern 2018 in rouen vor
perspektive auf das video auch da schon
präsent nun dass ich es mal richtig
verstehe es gibt ja verschiedene
regulation ebenen die zu klären werden
zb eine wer verwaltet die infrastruktur
ja so wie man es beim internet auch hat
sein dass private konzerne sind es
regierungen wer verwaltet das
regelsystem in diesen spaces und wer
verwaltet zum beispiel die technologie
die das ermöglichen also das ist ja
nicht so dass das eine frage ist sondern
das sind gleich mehrere fragen weil es
sich ja um die ganze welt handelt ja
total was sie ansprechen ist die idee
desto dao also dezentrale autonome
organisation die idee ist praktisch es
gibt jetzt konzerne wie meter wie viele
andere die zentral organisiert sind dh
dasitzen personen an einem ort die
sprechen miteinander und da werden auch
zum beispiel die daten verwaltet und
diese idee dieser dieser dezentralen
außerdem organisationen ist es gibt
überall ganz ganz viele verschiedenen
personen die teil dieser organisation
sind und die in einem ein bisschen
kompliziert aber bleibt bei mir in einem
in einem blog chain verfahren abstimmen
das bedeutet nichts anderes als wenn wir
hier abstimmen würden dann wäre das
nicht so dass jeder das in seinem
geheimen kämmerlein macht und dann
irgendwann kommt kommt eine entscheidung
raus sondern wir würden das praktisch
alle in ein buch schreiben in ein buch
das wir alle auch zu hause haben sozial
bitcoin auch zoe bitcoin es ist die
blockzeiten technologie das heißt wenn
ich bei mir wenn mir die entscheidung
nicht gefallen hat die wir getroffen
haben und ich das durch streicher und
dann unsere leute für die wir diese welt
gebaut haben bei mir gucken sagen
menschenrechtler ist was ganz anderes
als die anderen vier dann wäre relativ
klar weil auch die entscheidungen in
diesen büchern festgehalten sind dass
das die richtige entscheidung ist nicht
viel aber und das richtig verstanden
also ein basisdemokratischer utopie
die unter wird das ist es also ich
natürlich ist das versprechen dass alles
dezentraler organisiert ist das schließt
aber aus meiner sicht nicht aus dass ich
trotzdem macht akkumulation ergeben in
diesem bereich so wie es jetzt eben
schon bei den gruppierungen haben für
einige wenige personen extrem viele erst
jetzt kontrollieren können ja insofern
leichter etwas skeptisch ich will
vielleicht noch einen punkt zu
regulierungsfragen sagen ich finde es
ganz wichtig dass man sich sehr
frühzeitig anschaut was da gerade
passiert und zwar sowohl was die
monopole praktiken anbetrifft was aber
ebenso was die content moderation
anbetrifft aber ich glaube dass wir bei
regulierungen auch nicht stehen bleiben
dürfen sondern es geht letztlich darum
dass wir alternativen zur plattform
ökonomie formulieren dass wir da auch so
ein bisschen unser technologisches
imaginäre meines pro tag lernen das sind
eben wesentlichen in diese konzerne die
zum beispiel über die gestaltung von
diesen profitieren märkten im stimmte
monopolstellung haben und auch mono
praktiken forcieren und wir sehen jetzt
natürlich das sind die großen player
google amazon facebook microsoft und so
weiter die eben einen großen scheer
haben innerhalb der digitalen ökonomie
und es eben schwierig ist überhaupt sich
gegen diese kanzlerin in irgendeiner
form durchzusetzen und ich würde eben
sagen wir müssen dringend darüber
nachdenken ob es nicht andere formen des
daten eigentums gibt also eben auch
kollektiv begriffen beispielsweise und
da gibt es auch ganz interessante
konzepte von data trust später kommen
bis auf seinem konzept von plattform
genossenschaften aber diese überlegung
betreffen ja die gesamte digitale sphäre
ja nicht nur diesen spezielle segment
der es eines meter wird sondern dass
genau das zu machen problematisch aber
ich würde eben sagen natürlich werden
wir mit blick auf die macht also mit
tränen in der in der gegenwärtigen
digitalen ökonomie werden wir im wetter
weiß natürlich genau die gleichen
probleme haben also ich glaube nicht
dass sich das internet da irgendwie
dezentraler gestalten wird sondern für
mich ist eigentlich klar die
monopolisten haben ja auch die
netzwerkeffekte die haben ja schon die
user aggregiert und kann natürlich jetzt
im prinzip müssen sie den nur eine
kleine tür offen weise neben zum wetter
war's ja facebook beispielsweise also
ich glaube das ist relativ
offensichtlich dass es so läuft
natürlich ist es auch facebook intention
ich glaube was auch vielleicht noch eine
spannende sache ist wenn uns überlegen
welche gesellschaften haben wir dann in
diesen mittelwerten das wird ja nicht so
sein dass mark zuckerberg oder wer auch
immer das dann macht sagt ach übrigens
das hier ist die politik die in diesem
winter gefahren wird sondern sie geben
sich erstmal unpolitisch was aber nicht
bedeutet dass diese dass diese räume
ohne politik funktionieren würden die
politik ist nur im kot und da wird es
dann auch spannend wenn wir nämlich an
vertrags theorien denken wir denken an
thomas hobbes der gesagt hat hirn er
früher bei der naturzustand kampf aller
gegen alle das leben des kurz brutal und
dann haben wir die gesellschafter haben
den vertrag unterschrieben gegeben
einige rechte ab für die sicherheit
damals sagt hoax ja auch wir haben den
wir haben den vertrag nicht
unterschrieben da wird das aber so sein
wie unterzeichnen agbs da wird es ein
gesetz haben sind wir mit expliziert
jahren aber interessant ist ja ich
verstehe absolut das ist diese
regulierungs diskussion braucht die
schreib mir ganz ganz wichtig zu sein
zumal wir ja gesagt haben wir nicht
freiwillig entscheiden können nicht teil
davon zu sein oder nur wenn ihr dann so
hohe soziale kosten vielleicht in kauf
nehmen aber die frage kann ja auch noch
einmal sein ist das nicht alles ein
großes ablenkungsmanöver das stichwort
eskapismus die ganze frage was machen
wir eigentlich und wenn man mal die
science fiction literatur anschaut sie
haben schon snow crash erwähnt aber auch
der magix zb dass ich das natürlich
immer situationen in dem wir in
virtuelle welt sind uns begeben weil die
andere ursprungs welt zerstört ist durch
eine umweltkatastrophe durch einen
atomaren krieg dadurch dass eine
artificial intelligence übernommen hat
um diese frage bin ich schon ganz wie
denn die kann ja auch ganz am anfang in
dem in dem film vor haben wir nicht
eigentlich genügend probleme in der
rauen welt und beginnen wir nicht uns
sozusagen in einem spielhaus in einem
puppenhaus zurückzuziehen weil wir mit
der realen welt nicht mehr zu tun haben
wir raus letztlich die welt ist verloren
jetzt tue ich so also wie sie nicht
bräuchte und gehen wann genau ist gerade
nochmal etwas was ich nicht eigentlich
ein bisschen traurig stimmt ich würde
sagen ist das auf jeden fall ein
ablenkungsmanöver und das ist vor allem
das wetter es wird keines der probleme
lösen die wir momentan in denen wir uns
gegenübersehen also weder die
politischen probleme es ist zu erwarten
dass ich weiter gehende
radikalisierungen ergeben von
politischen akteuren in diesem
geschlossenen räumen auch im adwords die
wir jetzt schon von social media kennen
es wird auch zu erwarten sein dass ich
eine gänzlich neue digitale ökonomie
angeht die durchaus soziale
ungleichheiten reproduziert stichwort
gold farming haben wir gar nicht darüber
gesprochen aber da geht es eben darum
dass wirklich sehr prekäre von der
clique work reproduziert werden in auf
einem globalen maßstab und zudem
natürlich die ökologischen kommt nicht
richtig weg war das ist im prinzip im
gaming also eine strategie das zumeist
westliche spieler
zumeist schlechter gestellte spieler im
globalen süden mehr oder weniger
implizit beauftragen etwa waffen zu
erspielen skins zu erspielen francis l
versteht was man plastisch zu machen
geben in acht stunden am tag irgendetwas
tun damit andere menschen das spiel und
das ist hochgradig monotone arbeit dich
sehr schlecht bezahlt ist im prinzip das
was david greve als bullshit job
bezeichnet hat in einer neuen dimension
würde ich daher von software ist kappis
bleiben ein großer freundeskreis muss
ich natürlich in einer welt leben weiß
auch gar nicht ob philosophie letztlich
nichts anderes sein könnte als eine sehr
interessante form von eskapismus aber
wollen wir doch mal durch diese
standardsituation der technologie kritik
zu weit rauben das braucht niemand das
ist ungerecht dass es ökologisch nicht
gut es ist doch eigentlich eine
wahnsinnig schöne sache wenn man sich in
virtuelle räume begeben kann und nicht
über die wirklichkeit nachdenken muss
also ich sehe die politische linie die
sie von aber den eskapismus als sich zu
verdammt das geht dann doch ein bisschen
weit oder da wieder ein haken ja und
zwar wenn man sich verschiedene
technologien anguckt die wir hatten wir
hatten den home computer mit der maus
und der tastatur da war es dann so ich
immer noch
dass hier
also habe ich sag mal genau dazu sagen
als wir angefangen haben den zu haben
offen der größeren breite wir haben die
leute damit umgehen gelernt durch spiele
durch solitär da war die idee man zieht
die eine karte rüber und legt sie da ab
so haben wir mit der maus um gegen der
als das iphone aufgaben oder das
smartphone generell da war ein ganz
großes spiel war angry birds wo man
diesen vogel mit dieser steinschleuder
auf praktisch baumhäuser geschossen und
auch hier das wischen und das loslassen
was zentral für den umgang mit diesen
technologien jetzt mit der virtuellen
realität haben wir auch spiele die man
natürlich von außen als eskapismus
betrachten kann dies auch teilweise
logischerweise sind aber da wird nicht
stehenbleiben und was ich auch noch
sagen würde um auch die andere position
stark zu machen sozusagen hier technik
ist nicht nur schlecht ich glaube nicht
dass virtuelle realität dass bleiben
wird was racing in seinem
1974 erschienen buch utopia state in
energie das nennt eine erfahrungs
maschine wir erinnern uns noch mal kurz
man schließt sich an eine maschine
anderen maschine die vorprogrammierten
lauf hat man kann sich nicht wirklich
frei entscheiden und alles ist aber
total schöne alles ist großartig es gibt
nur glück so wird virtuelle virtuelle
realität nicht funktionieren weil das
eintreten ist im besten fall in gewisser
weise freiwillig und die erfahrung die
die man macht sind auch wiederum eigene
entscheidung diesen nicht
vorprogrammiert das ist kein film da
steht es total gut aber der punkt ist
doch ich glaube sogar dass ist doch
richtig ist das war auch zb schmerz
vorkommen wird enttäuschung vorkommen
wird weil unser leben ist ja reich und
bunt und und befriedigend letztlich auch
dadurch dass es diese wechsel gibt auch
in stimmungen zb also mir leuchtet total
ein dass es nicht einfach der rosarote
traum ist aber um das noch einmal zu
sagen und um gegen dich zu argumentieren
mit dem fk ps muss ich mir nicht
vorstellen wir haben sämtliche strände
versaut alle korallenriffe sind kaputt
weil ihr uns nicht um den klimawandel
kümmern weil uns das nicht interessiert
ihr könnt aber mit virtual reality super
anschauen dann müssen wir es vielleicht
auch gar nicht retten weil die haben uns
ja gerettet in virtuellen was ich schon
etwas nicht so genau so wie man den mars
besiedeln können wenn die erde kaputt
das kann man sagen wir machen jetzt dass
ich habe immer nutzen nicht mehr diesen
plan jetzt ja das könnte man sagen aber
ist das denn so dass wir wirklich die
die koran griffen nun nachbauen können
oder gibt es zum beispiel auch den
gedanken dass jemand der zum beispiel
visuell denkt jemand der visuell lernt
jemand der visuell umgeht der könnte
vielleicht besser verstehen dass auch
umweltschutz wichtig ist in dem man es
mal indem man es mal gesehen hat wenn er
damit applaus ja und die leute aber ich
glaube man darf die leute auch nichts
darüber machen als sie sind also
angenommen wir sind in fünf jahren da
dass sich das wirklich anfühlt wie
tauchen die haben ja nicht vergessen
dass das aus der realität kommt und dann
wenn die sagen mensch ich muss mir sagen
lassen bis hin zu argument so sind an
sich schlecht aber dadurch dass man
pädagogisch mit affen in kontakt und
schützt man dann die achter dahin um
einen nachmieter das irgendwie sie
sagten hopst so schön das leben ist kurz
hat grausam das versprechen dieses meter
ist das anders das leben ist lang
potenziell unendlich es ist nicht
umkämpft es ist nicht grausam ich glaube
zum beispiel nicht dass es in diesem
metier es viele leute gibt die darm
grippe kaufen werden oder hirntumore ja
und das ist ja teil unseres lebens
insofern denke ich nicht dass man sagen
kann ja den schmerz dann gibt's
vielleicht einfach das was unseres leben
eine tragische dimension gibt und man
kann sagen das ist für unser moralisches
stars ein wichtig das wird doch niemand
kaufen
das wird die man kaufen das haben wir
aber auch hier schon also das ist ja es
wird gleich ist hier passiert halt nun
mal das ist der unterschied klar die
frage ist wo alles daran besser ist aber
mir ging es jetzt zu schnell mit dem zu
wenig um den korallenriffen weil ich ich
habe einmal am anfang die frage gestellt
was ist eigentlich der unterschied ob
ich das coral reef in real sehe oder
virtuellen und die frage ist doch wenn
das so gut ist warum soll diese
pädagogische erfahrung überhaupt noch
ziehen warum soll ich nicht einfach
fragen macht sie überhaupt einen
unterschied ob ist das korallenriff noch
real gibt also ist es nicht eine alte
denke sind jetzt nicht alle puma hier am
tisch warum sollen die nicht einfach
alle diese virtuellen welten da
reingehen ich würde aber trotzdem noch
mal ein bisschen stark machen dass er
natürlich selbst mit immensen
ökologischen kosten verbunden ist ja
also um das wetter war es umzusetzen so
zuckerberg selbst natürlich braucht es
diese zehn bis zwölf zeichen beginn von
denen niemand genau weiß man die kommen
werden es braucht einer tausendfachen
erhöhung der rechenkapazität es braucht
eine womöglich gänzlich neuen digitalen
infrastruktur das sind alles dimensionen
die extrem viel mit ökologischen kosten
zu tun haben und ich würde so ein
bisschen bezweifeln dass das
rechtfertigt sozusagen nur dass man
vielleicht eine andere immer sieben
erfahrung hat dass man sich vielleicht
anders in
andere nichtmenschliche identitäten zum
beispiel reinversetzen kann auch das ist
ja ein versprechen ja dass man eine
andere sensibilität entwickelt da würde
ich so ein bisschen glaube ich schon
hinterfragen ist das sozusagen wirklich
diese summe ist es das wert auch genau
ja ich bin total eurer meinung ich mache
jetzt mal den advocatus diaboli branche
stehen die lebenswelt des trägers und
würde sagen ja ist er also vor computern
und smartphones haben wir auch gut
gelebt das hat jetzt irgendwie haben wir
das wirklich gebraucht auch jetzt sind
natürlich massive energetische kosten
mit finanzwirtschaft mit digitalität und
alldem verbunden es kann sein dass wir
lösungen finden die für probleme die wir
jetzt haben wir uns aber nicht
vorstellen können weil es vielleicht
eine der technologien sei dabei ist die
uns noch mal auf eine andere idee bringt
und das andere was ich sagen würde wir
reden ja jetzt darüber als würden wir
praktisch in zehn jahren hier nicht mehr
sitzen würden wir nicht mehr rausgehen
wir lassen uns alles liefern und haben
den ganzen tag dieses ding auf ich
glaube dass virtuelle realität und was
meter wäre es ersetzen wird sind
bildschirm anwendungen sind sachen wo
wir jetzt auch schon das handy in der
hand haben wo wir computer haben das
metallbörse wird aber nicht den
samstagabend ersetzen ist nicht alle
zumindest nicht alle samstagabend weil
man sieht es ja jetzt schon die
zugriffszahlen auf viele großen news
netzwerke und spiele und so sind am
wochenende so niedrig wie nie das heißt
dass gegen das wochenende kommt das
wetter war es glaube ich und dass auch
meine hoffnung kommt das mädchen nicht
an und wird auch nicht ankommen würden
sie das zu so eine art anthropologischen
these weiten wir haben ein realitäts
bedürfnis dass sich nicht austricksen
ich würde sagen ja dass man dann
wiederum nicht versteht wenn man thomas
ernst nimmt wenn er sagen würde dass ich
alles realität und genau die frage ist
natürlich wenn wir technologisch
wirklich so weit sind dass wir alle
erfahrungen so gut simulieren kann ja
dann ist natürlich die frage gibt sich
das auch ist das nicht auch eine neue
realität wir haben wenn wir tatsächlich
genauso interagieren kann mit personen
wie wir das in der sogenannten realen
realität können wäre natürlich die frage
wo ist die diskussion eigentlich noch zu
ziehen
technologien werden zu einem zweck
erfunden und dann ergeben sich zwecke an
die niemand der diese technologien
erfunden hat jemals denkt dagegen soll
ich aber auch nicht antizipiert genau
daraus konsequenzen also auch das im
guten wie im schlechten aber natürlich
müsste man sagen wenn man kratos siebten
brief liest dann war die erfindung der
schrift keine so gute sache schlecht
fürs gedächtnis man konnte dinge
behaupten die man nicht argumentativ
einholen kann lassen wir das mal mit der
schrift das heißt sie nicht philosophen
als philosophen bei einer art prix
programmierten einstellungen zu sein das
lassen wir jetzt erstmal sind die nicht
an sich konservativ
würde sagen das kommt wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen auf die philosophie an oder
also es gibt natürlich wenn man sich an
der regatta rhi das technikverständnis
oder auch anwender stil er das sind auch
philosophen die eigentlich sagen würden
wir sind als menschen technologisch
verpasst ja also technologien gehen
sozusagen unsere eigenen existenz sogar
voraus ja wir sind als menschen könnte
anders macht das gleiche argument wir
sind angewiesen auf technologien um uns
überhaupt in der welt zurechtzufinden
wir sonst nichts gründen weil wir sonst
nichts kann weil wir keine orientierung
haben weil wir auch eigentlich überhaupt
nicht lebens überlebensfähig sind und da
würde ich eben sagen ist natürlich die
frage immer natürlich gibt es gewisse
ich würde sagen form auch das technik
effects in der philosophischen tradition
aber es gibt auch kritische bezugnahme
auf diesen technik affekt er
insbesondere eben in der dekonstruktion
etwa oder eben in der nachfolge oder dem
der kritischen leser der idas von von
werners tiger und ich würde auch noch
sagen eigentlich ist auch die virtuelle
realität und eventuell des mieters
irgendwann mit allem was wir schon
gesprochen haben aber auch eine gute
nachricht für die philosophie weil
philosophen und philosophinnen stellen
sie schon seit jahrtausenden die frage
was kann ich wissen über die außenwelt
was ist real was sind bezüge zwischen
menschen und natürlich wird durch
virtuelle realität sich diese frage auch
für menschen stellen sie sich mit
philosophie davor nicht
auseinandergesetzt haben das heißt durch
die virtuelle realität wachsen praktisch
philosophische fragen näher ans leben
das wir schon sagen dass wir vielleicht
auch immer er hat riesen putsch ich
glaube kein wort jeder der intensiv
geträumt hat hat genug anlass darüber
nachzudenken aber auch keine werfe
eine philosophische grundfragen die sich
immer schon stellt die kann ich
eigentlich wissen dass hier in der
realität leben um nicht in einer
simulation das ist ja schon das problem
von descartes bei vielen anderen
philosophen auch wie ich mir das
eigentlich
naja was würde sagen es gibt zwei arten
von simulationen einmal die perfekte
simulation in der die wirklich genau so
ist es gibt keine fehler es gibt nicht
wie in matrix die katze die die schwarze
katze die von zwei mal von rechts nach
links läuft
die perfekte simulation in der würden
wir in der leben könnten wir eigentlich
nur wissen wenn die macherinnen und
macher sich offenbaren wenn sie sagen
übrigens
herein berger sie sind eine simulation
und der rassistisch ist ja auch dass wir
eine möglichkeit ich hoffe award oder es
gibt natürlich die simulation die nicht
mehr sind und dass wir dann eine frage
der technik können wir irgendwelche
spektral wellen irgendwo sehen die
bestimmte muster werfen die auf eine
simulation hindeuten aber da sind wir
offenbar noch nicht zumindest habe ich
noch nicht davon gehört na ja die frage
war ja auch so ein bisschen warum sollte
uns die existenz von virtual reality
technologien anders darüber nachdenken
lassen das wäre meine gegenfrage was
ändert das irgendwie erinnert die
existenz der technologie irgendetwas
alles andere weise darüber nachzudenken
um sie nicht ich denke auch nicht dass
es da irgendwie eine
erkenntnistheoretische neue brisanz gibt
vor allem weil ich glaube das gibt weil
die geschlechtlichkeit die jungen gehen
gibt es ja auch schon seit jahrzehnten
ja das ist ja wirklich das muss man
immer sagen ich würde auch immer dieses
dieses innovations- versprechen von
zuckerberg etwas dekonstruieren wollen
der sich hinstellt und sagt nicoletta
bars das ist ja nicht sein begriffe also
das ist wirklich das ist total absurd
das ist wirklich merkwürdig weil die
versionierung silicon valley schon seit
jahren darüber sprechen im cyberspace
diskurs der 90er jahre taucht das
metaversum eben in anklang investieren
so ebenso genauso auf technologie
geschichtlich kann man bestimmte form
der technologischen simulation
zurückverfolgen in die 50er jahre mit
der sensor a machine von motten heiliger
also wo man eben auch eine motorradfahrt
durch manhattan simuliert hat und
tatsächlich auch den geruch mit
simuliert hat also das ist ja nichts
neues deshalb frage ich mich so ein
bisschen warum sollten wir weil facebook
jetzt sagt hier ist das produkt ja hier
ist unser patch zum meta bars warum
sollten wir jetzt anders über also ein
sollte nicht die richtig verstehe dass
sonnenberg sagt wir haben auch diese
idee geklaut
es ist wirklich ein sehr populäres ein
sehr breiten wirksames plagiat gewesen
und ich finde ehrlich gesagt also ist
natürlich marketing strategische
unglaublich intelligent gewesen auch zu
sagen wir
sagen nicht wir ist unser großer patch
zum etwas nicht nur das sondern wir
sagen auch wir nennen uns jetzt als
konzernleiter und seither habe ich den
eindruck dass ich eigentlich die
öffentlichkeit größtenteils
oder das dass sie den eindruck hat dass
das wetter war es irgendwie
notwendigerweise was mit facebook zu tun
hat oder auch dass das vielleicht sogar
facebooks idee ist ja wir sind in die
falle geworden dass unsere diskussion
ist er auch seit monaten über dieses
thema und fast nur nach auch in der den
ganzen tag welt über dieses thema weil
mark zuckerberg so eine diskurs macht
hat ja man hätte auch früher anfangen
kann die immobilienbranche und was
spielt bisschen schon eine größere rolle
im team ist sehr sehr viele diskussionen
darüber ich frage mich einfach immer
noch was wäre denn wenn wir jetzt dieses
metallbörse ein anderes
virtuelles universe erfinden können wie
das denn aussehen wenn ihr es wirklich
utopisch denken könnten auf wäre den
anklamer müssen das ist so eine schöne
große frage die sich in dieser realität
nicht stellt er ist von zeitlichen
begrenzung
betroffen und in dem sinne glaube ich
diese utopischen horizonte das ist schön
ich glaube dass wir über dieses
mitarbeiters über unsere eigene
verfasstheit neu nachdenken können das
ist gleich erkenntnistheoretische impuls
der wirksam seien heute aber meine
letzte frage an die beiden bevor wir in
dieser wirklichkeit auseinander gehen
wenn es denn so wäre dass dieses
networks alle versprechen einlösen
könnte und sie könnten dort dauerhaft
verweilen müssten es vielleicht sogar
frost auf was würden sie an dieser welt
vermissen
also das ist für den ganz ganz
komplizierte frage wer müsst euch
wirklich lange drüber nachdenken
ich weiß gerade keinen fall ich muss
wirklich sagen für mich ist das fast
noch zu hypothetisch gefragten ich halte
es eigentlich für ausgeschlossen dass es
so kommt gut also die frage wird sich
nicht stellen wenn wir annehmen es kommt
wirklich erstes das ist wie hier dann
wird glaube ich ein zentraler aspekt
fehlen und dass der zufall denn es wird
ein programm sein es wird ein code sein
es wird ein konzept sein irgendjemand
wird sich eine welt überlegt haben und
ich glaube nicht dass da wirklich ein
zufall einen platz hat und begegnungen
die man vielleicht hier einfach die sich
hier einfach ergeben als ereignis die
glaube ich werden wir davon wissen
müssen und da werden einige philosophen
vielleicht sagen den zufall gibt es auch
in der realität nicht
hinzufügen und vielleicht einfach die
unlust morgens aufzustehen ich würde die
ich für mich
das nicht
[Gelächter]
die fragen sie nicht gelöst aber sie
sind geöffnet und genau das wollen wir
hier tun herzlichen dank dafür
fraunhofer er hat dankeschön
vielen dank auch ihnen zu hause wie er
sich für philosophie interessiert
zurzeit ist die erste viel expo in
vollem gange ein schweizweit das
festival oder philosophie das programm
finden sie auf der website nächste woche
trifft f boss hat den schriftsteller
sensoren war roger und spricht mit ihm
über kriegen flucht aber auch über kunst
und schönheit und jetzt gleich gibt es
hier mal wieder richtig was zu entdecken
nämlich eine der ganz großen
wissenschaftlichen pioniere in der
schweiz und zudem eine wichtige figur
der friedensbewegung werden sie also
dran und werden sie gärten trug erkennen
eine gute zeit in der realität gespielt
[Musik]